a tentative olive branch loaded with
consequences
the spanish prime minister has been
pushing hard to provide talks with
catalan separatists
and hoping that a pardon for the
movement's nine imprisoned leaders
can open the way for dialogue
the spanish government has taken this
decision because it's the best for
catalonia
the best for spain and corresponds to
the spirit of harmony and coexistence in
the spanish constitution
[Applause]
it's not without opposition sanchez
finds himself in the middle of a storm
outside of catalonia it is deeply
unpopular
more than 60 percent of the country
against the move
and parties from the center to the hard
right have capitalized on that
discontent
for the pro-secessionist movement the
pardons do not go
far enough the catalan leader said only
an amnesty would be acceptable
as he echoed calls to continue the fight
for independence
it's time for an amnesty and the right
to self-determination
it's time to agree on a referendum it's
time for a solution to achieve
more internal consensus
[Applause]
the illegal independence referendum in
2017
triggered the biggest political crisis
that the country had seen in decades
the nine secessionist leaders were
sentenced in 2019 for their roles in the
vote
including catalonia's vice premiere
spain's supreme court which oversaw the
trial has also rejected the pardons
as it says those sentenced have shown no
remorse
while the ruling is non-binding it could
be cited in possible future legal
challenges
in the constitutional court which could
send the nine
back to prison the difficulty for the
pro-secessionists argument is that while
it is very vocal it is still in the
minority in catalonia
being part of spain is still just about
the preferred option there
mr sanchez's dilemma is that he is
leading a minority government and can
ill afford to squander further support
in the parliament he also needs the
support of catalan nationalist parties
and their leaders know that this peace
offering won't be extended by the prime
minister's opponents
it is an enormous gamble yet those
determined to move on say the pardons
are the only way to repair the deep
divisions that still linger
between the two sides sonia gallego al
jazeera